qué gusto de verdad muy buenas noches mi
nombre es rodrigo tovar
qué pasaría si pudiéramos vender nuestro
tiempo vender y comprar nuestro tiempo
qué pasaría si yo les pudiera pagar 100
pesos por cada hora de su vida si
ustedes me pudieran traspasar un poco de
esta vida que ustedes tienen esto lo
empezó a pensar ahora cuando cumplo casi
45 años y empiezas a darte cuenta que te
empiezas a acercar más hacia la otra
parte
hablando de que la vida termina
aproximadamente en promedio a los 80
años si empiezo a darme cuenta que ya
pasé esta línea y entonces empiezo a
pensar en todo el tiempo que tal vez
perdí platicaba con mis alumnos el otro
día y decía vendan me vendan me una hora
de su vida
si me venden un día podrían ganar 2400
pesos
si me venden un mes sería un poco más es
más de 70 mil pesos si hablamos de un
año estaríamos hablando de como 876 mil
pesos pero si me venden 10 años de su
vida estarían ganando 8 millones 760 mil
pesos los cuales serían muy muy buenos
nos quedamos platicando así durante una
hora y no hubo ningún joven al cual yo
pudiera convencer de que me vendiera un
poco de tiempo me dijeron que no porque
porque el tiempo y la vida no tiene un
precio
entonces yo les pregunté entonces por
qué lo desperdician delante de mí
porque el tiempo pasa y lo llenan de
nada
desde hace unos años sucedió algo
en algún sueño me di cuenta que yo venía
de otro planeta
en ese otro planeta
la diferencia era que
el sistema de creencias nos hacía que
cada uno de nosotros no si no se
sintiera maravilloso extraordinario en
ese planeta del cual yo me sentía todos
podíamos caminar y venir en libertad
no existía en la crítica no existían las
palabras fuertes no existían las
palabras malas
entonces se podía caminar de otra manera
en este sueño caminé hasta el borde de
mi ventana y de mi espalda salieron dos
alas enormes
pude volar
por supuesto si yo le contara esto a las
personas dentro de nuestro sistema
pensarían que yo estoy loco y me
mandarían a un psicólogo a un psiquiatra
así que quiero pedirles que guarden este
secreto
cuando era niño la vida me dio la
oportunidad de crear por primera vez en
el kinder la maestra me dijo que tenía
que hacer un pescado un pescado en una
hoja normal y que tenía que colorearlo
de un color todo perfectamente bien
eliminado y sin salirme de la rayita en
ese momento puse en mi pescado ahí y yo
sentí que tenía que colorearlo de todos
los colores posibles así que tomé los 24
colores que tenía hilo color y una y
otra y otra y otra y otra y otra de
repente la maestra se acercó a mí y me
dijo tenemos un problema contigo rodrigo
no sabe seguir instrucciones y llamaron
a mi madre
mi madre llegó y le dijeron que no podía
seguir instrucciones primera vuelta a
verme mi hijo dijo por qué pintaste este
pescado de tantos colores sino como se
te indico eligiéndose yo sentí que el
pescado se sentía mejor de colores y
creo que que le hacía feliz estar de
colores y me dice bueno che
mira vamos a hacer que la maestra piense
que se puede seguir instrucciones así
que toma un color y pintando de uno solo
ok tome el negro y pinte todo de color
negro
y su ojo con lo rojo
porque ahora estaba triste
los años pasaron y este personaje que me
pidieron que agarrara para ser más
normal me fue atrapando por aquel
entonces a mi madre le recomendaron que
me dedicara
porque me consideraban un niño
hiperquinético hiperactivo muy distraído
pero mi madre en un acto de rebeldía
hizo un acuerdo conmigo y me dijo mira
tú trata de comportarte como alguien
normal y yo no hago esto de la
medicación y llegamos a un acuerdo el
problema es que este personaje me fue
ganando y para cuando yo llegué a la
adolescencia yo ya estaba perdido en
este personaje que no tiene alma ya no
era yo
era el pescado negro con el ojo rojo
y cuando llegue a esa edad empecé a
tener muchísimos problemas con la
autoridad mi rebeldía no sabía hacia
dónde ir
por aquel entonces tuve la oportunidad
de encontrarme con maestros que me
enseñaron que la filosofía la lógica la
ética
eran buenos instrumentos para defender
mis creencias me enseñaron un poco de
antropología y también un poco de
brujería
era divertido ser diferente
de verdad me gustaba
yo sé que tal vez es como un poco
extraño que se hable de uno pero para mí
el actor de teatro el actor hace
catarsis y tiene que hablar de él para
ponerse aquí
y que la gente lo vea tal y cual es yo
no puedo llegar aquí y hablarles de lo
que creo que sé yo sé lo que sé de mí y
tal vez me equivocado muchísimas veces
sí seguramente pero tienen que ver al
hombre al que está aquí al que se
equivoca no al que cree que tiene la
razón y que puede venir aquí a decirles
lo que tienen que hacer porque hay que
dudar de todo
y a partir de esto piden las buenas
decisiones a partir de la duda a partir
de decidir lo que yo quiero ser
por ese entonces en la adolescencia mis
padres siempre me decían nosotros
sabemos lo que es mejor para ti
sonaba coherente pero no sonaba lógico
porque yo era testigo de que a veces ni
siquiera sabían lo que era mejor para
ellos entonces como sabían lo que era
mejor para mí si tampoco sabían lo que
era mejor para ellos además yo era un
ser humano distinto yo tenía otras otros
sentimientos otras sensaciones
poco a poco me fui internando en
diferentes mundos
mi vida se convirtió en algo así como
en una persona sin alas alguien que
caminaba como un zombi no tenía ganas de
hacer nada a veces no tenía ganas ni
siquiera de levantarme no me encontraba
ni a mí mismo
hasta que un día te encontré
el teatro y el teatro me mostró la
posibilidad de decidir y de ser libre
cómo
y mi maestro me engañó
de verdad me dijo que el teatro era
fácil y no lo era me mostró cosas
completamente distintas
y entonces empecé a comprender cómo las
estructuras centrales te podían ir y
llevar a diferentes espacios y a
diferentes momentos
empecé a pensar que decidir era bueno
y de verdad lo que dije hace rato sobre
los padres no es que yo tenga algo en
contra de los padres de familia yo soy
un padre de familia
y todos los días me enfrento a querer
hacer que mis hijos puedan decidir de
buena manera el otro día mi hijo más
pequeño me decía papá oye no quiero
hacer la tarea luego va muy bien no la
hagas saber papá pero si no la hago la
maestra me va a regañar cuando entonces
hazla no papá pero es que no la quiero
hacer porque de verdad prefiero estar
haciendo otra cosa bueno dijo que no la
hagas pues pasa pero si no la hago
entonces no voy a aprender está
posteando entonces esa es la fuente de
saber papá que no se supone que me
tienes que regañar o ayudarme luego a
ver hijo es tu decisión
si quieres hacer la isla si no no habrá
consecuencias pero es tu decisión
y dice papá tengo 5 años
y le dije sí y ya eres un hombre libre
de decidir lo que tú quieres hacer
y sabes que creo que si la voy a hacer
porque quiero pasar el año y cuando sea
grande quiero ser licenciado o quiero
ser arquitecto eso sí me preocupo
dije oye eso eso no es una carrera te
vas a morir de hambre
en esta familia pura gente decente
actores
uno tiene que ir cambiando el sistema de
creencias ahora mis hijos piensan que
ser actor es algo bueno
pero antes no hay gente que ha llegado a
hablar conmigo y me dice maestro le
traigo aquí a mis hijos a mi hija a mi
hijo sólo quiero decirle que bueno yo ya
hablé con ella y ya le dije que en estos
ambientes pues puros muertos de hambre
de prostitutas alcohólicos y drogadictos
y yo
gracias buenas tardes
mire sinceramente yo ninguno de ellos y
no tengo nada en contra de nadie pero
eso tiene que ver con lo que les enseñan
en casa no lo que vengan a aprender aquí
todo lo que dijo hay en todos lados y si
no preguntan en la cámara de diputados
como en el teatro para mí es muy
importante esto sin significado no hay
acción sino un texto no hay una acción
un actor no puede moverse si no sabe
hacia dónde sí siempre tenemos a una la
improvisación tenemos que saber qué
hacer entonces el significado de algo
tiene que ver con la acción de algo y yo
siempre he pensado que si algo no tiene
un significado no tendría una acción en
este mundo que yo les platico que son
las palabras narcotráfico violencia
feminicidio corrupción no existen
entonces como no las conocen no hay
acción no suceden
pero fomentamos las palabras de las
cuales no queremos saber nada y hacemos
que existan
si uno no le platica a sus hijos ciertas
cosas puedes mantenerlos hasta cierto
grado
salvados de las situaciones claro se las
tienes que decir y entonces tienen que
existir pero qué pasaría si volviéramos
a empezar si pudiéramos comprar el
tiempo
cuando llegue a los 18 años sucedió algo
emocionante en mi vida llegué con mis
padres me senté con ellos y les dije
quiero ser actor quiero estudiar teatro
bueno mi mamá pensó y yo les vi la cara
así como de que nos equivocamos que
hicimos mal
este niño que se nos salió de las manos
tengo que decirles que mis padres
realmente siempre fueron unos buenos
padres muy buenos siempre me crearon con
amor nunca hubo excesos en casa nunca
veo violencia de verdad era era un
ambiente bueno rico entonces me permitió
desarrollarme de alguna manera y
entonces yo quería hacer esto pero
cuando llegamos a esa encrucijada
tuvimos que partir yo salí de casa
estuve un tiempo fuera
hasta que regrese y por alguna razón
hicimos una especie de pacto entonces yo
estudié otra carrera que no tenía nada
que ver con el teatro sin embargo no
dejé el teatro a un lado estudiaba una
carrera y estudiaba en la otra
pronto mis padres se dieron cuenta de mi
doble vida
y eso fue una tragedia
durante mucho tiempo
mis padres pensaron que lo único que yo
quería era
estar seguro
por ese entonces la vida me empezó a
llevar a esta ruleta y cuando me di
cuenta ya estaba otra vez con este
pescado color negro con su ojo rojo
y
me encontré trabajando de saca copias en
una entidad de gobierno
después fui capturista
ayudante administrativo o sea el que
corre y va por las tortas
hice algunas cosas en power point
y después de ocho años ya tenía mi
quincena
como agua
n 21
tenía mi
aguinaldo tenía mi fondo de jubilación y
hasta podía tener mi casita de infonavit
era la vida perfecta
pero yo no me sentía bien
yo sentía que estaba alejado de lo que
yo siempre había soñado
de dónde vengo las palabras
no existen como tal la gente aprende a
convivir y hablarse cara a cara
a abrazarse
cuántas veces estamos al lado de una
persona y podemos ver y sentir que
necesita algo de nosotros pero por pena
no hablamos con esa persona tal vez sea
un desconocido pero estamos fuera de
rango estamos fuera de esta capacidad de
hablar decía mi abuelo que cuando él se
sube al tranvía todo se subía y se
saludaban buenos días señor miguel
buenos días todos se conocían sabían a
dónde iban donde trabajaban entonces
cuando alguien malo llegaba lo
reconocían de inmediato pero hoy es muy
fácil para los malos meterse entre
nosotros porque nosotros no nos
comunicamos las palabras han dejado de
existir
en mi planeta en las redes sociales se
hacen en las calles la gente habla cara
a cara corazón a corazón
los verdaderos influencers son los más
viejos los que saben
los que te dan la experiencia
allá nuestros viejos están enaltecidos
por nosotros
no no se embolsan las compras en el
súper
allá nadie tiene que encontrarse para
ser popular
no necesitas ser popular porque todos
nos sabemos maravillosos y
extraordinarios la popularidad no existe
porque la palabra no existe
en mi mundo superman no tiene
superpoderes es super honesto es super
querido y es super chingón y todo el
mundo lo supera ma
en mi mundo
dios camina por las calles y nadie le
reclama nada porque todos saben qué
hacer y que han hecho
en el mundo no hay maldad
porque la palabra tampoco existe
ustedes dirán bueno entonces este tipo
que hace aquí si se queja tanto de este
mundo
no lo estoy tratando de investigar
aún aquí no sé qué estoy haciendo lo
único que trato es de pensar en que
cuando la hora me llegue y mi vida se
acabe tienes la posibilidad de decir si
la viví de vivir de vivir bien no
necesito más tiempo me siento bien no
tendría por qué comprarle nada a nadie
cuando yo muera no quiero de verle nadie
nada a nadie ni siquiera a mí
quiero decir viví fui feliz y si lo que
yo quería
en mi mundo romeo y julieta se pueden
amar sin tener que morir en mi mundo
hamlet no le tiene miedo a su familia
porque lo vaya a traicionar en mi mundo
aquiles y héctor juegan al fútbol y no a
la guerra
escribimos de manera distinta hablamos
de manera distinta claro puede ser una
alegoría o puede ser una utopía
pero nos hace falta saber sócrates y
platón hablaban de este mundo perfecto y
donde están ahora a quien los conoce
ellos deberían ser nuestros influencers
deberíamos de estudiar aristóteles
hacerle un poquito de caso a freud pero
no para ir a quejarse sino para
entendernos
a tiempo
si esto el tiempo
siempre me pasa lo mismo de verdad bueno
ni siquiera era la conferencia que
quería darles
la verdad es que siempre me distraigo y
creo que solo me queda un minuto no lo
sé
y ya pasó el tiempo que yo quería y mamá
te falle
otra vez me distraje no sé seguir
instrucciones por eso a veces me siento
como fuera de este mundo
un día
me gustaría encontrarme en la calle
donde sea
y que nuestra obra y nuestra escena
fuera diferente
tal vez yo no pueda memorizar la cara de
cada uno de ustedes
tal vez no pueda
pero les prometo que si un día en la
calle me dicen oye tú yo te vi
los voy a saludar
yo no necesito un celular
para ponerme en contacto con nadie
porque soy un ser humano yo no necesito
una máquina para hablar con nadie me
gusta la piel me gusta el sentido me
gusta el beso me enamoro de la gente
porque siendo que somos
tipos atrapados en aparatos diciendo
mentiras
de verdad espero que algún día nos
podamos encontrar caminar platicar y que
ustedes igual que yo puedan llegar al
final de su vida pensando en que no
deben nada a la vida sin querer comprar
tiempo
porque ustedes también pueden despertar
en la mitad de la noche y sentir que
salen alas de su espalda pero no le
digan a nadie
es un secreto tal vez algún día
caminemos
y si este sistema de creencias cambia
podemos decir
yo conocí a un hombre que decía que
venía de otro planeta
y ese hombre cambio a otro y ese a otro
y ese a otro y dice a otro y dicen que
hubo un mundo una vez
en una escena como una obra de teatro
en la cual los hombres no hablaban solo
hablaban por celular los hombres tenían
violencia entre ellos sino se amaban
pero es una historia
porque hoy en nuestro mundo todo es
distinto
yo les invito a cambiar su escena
a realizar una acción dramática a un
punto de quiebre y cambiar por completo
la vida mostrarle a sus hijos el poder
de decidir y la libertad de decidir
amarlos y besarlos antes de separarse
es lo único que puedo hacer y aún así
crearme puedo no tener razón
es la verdad que yo creo
es la verdad que me enseñó el teatro y
lo aplicó a mi vida
así que ojalá un día nos encontremos y
podamos hablar de esto
ojalá podamos abrazarnos porque de
verdad eso es lo que yo siempre he
querido
deseo de todo corazón
que igual que yo un día puedan encontrar
a su pescado de colores muchas gracias
[Aplausos]